you know i was kind of just happily in
my in my lab
working with my spiders and wasps and
ants and i didn't want to have to like
sit up from my workbench
but i did so i was actually okay with it
destroying my career
because i
i wanted to be able to speak the truth
they sent me a message through the
paypal system saying that if i want to
find out why my account was turned off
have an attorney submit a subpoena a
legal subpoena to find out they recently
also shut down mom's for liberty account
their paypal account so this is sort of
a pattern that they have of people that
they disagree with politically on this i
can no longer use etsy i'm permanently
banned from etsy i'm pretty benign and
so for that to happen to me for them to
like think that i'm sort of beyond the
pale to be treated on par with like a
domestic terrorist need to shut down his
ways he can get income
yeah it's it's it's completely insane i
don't know how he got here there's so
many biologists who reached out saying
that they won't even they don't even
want to like a tweet they'll send me a
dm saying i liked your tweet but i
couldn't like your tweet
hold on what you're telling me is that
there are biologists at prominent
institutions who don't believe that
there is more than two sexes but they
will denounce someone like you who says
it
because they're terrified of the
repercussions for their career is that
what you're telling me 100
[Music]
did you know that you can ask guess your
questions that's right when you join our
local community not only will you know
who we're about to interview you have
the opportunity to ask them your
questions you have the chance to ask
jordan peterson the co-founder of
extinction rebellion nigel farage
douglas murray andrew doyle jeff norco
simon evans larry elder david badil
andrew sullivan megan kelly julia
hartley brewer lord nigel lawson brett
weinstein inaudible
dr david nutt jimmy dore gad sad blair
white melissa chen trevor phillips
ayanne hersey ali glenn lowry bridger
fair to see jim rickards carl benjamin
and so many more plus we're about to
interview some of the biggest guests
in the world we can't name them just yet
but trust me they're huge metaphorically
speaking not just because they're
american our locals gives you access to
a great community of like-minded people
where you can share memes and make new
and problematic friends you also get
early access to live shows and we're
about to release details of our tour so
you'll want to know about that as well
on the higher tiers you get monthly
supporter calls and the opportunity to
have a meal or a call with us click the
link below or go to
trigonometry.locals.com
and join the community that's
trigonometry.locals.com
we'll see you there
hello and welcome to trigonometry on the
road from the usa i'm francis foster i'm
constantly kissing and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
and returning guest today is an
evolutionary biologist who's paying
quite a heavy price at the moment for
saying some very obvious things colin
wright welcome back to trigonometry
thanks for having me on thanks for
coming to my place yeah thanks for
having us we really appreciate it um
look man let's quickly remind everybody
who you are last time we spoke to you is
in the middle of the lockdowns and it
was all going a bit crazy who are you
how are you where you are what's been
your journey through life that leads me
to be sitting so much has happened so
much has happened just since we last
chatted so i'll try to
maybe jump off from then a little little
more in the back um so i'm an
evolutionary biologist i was working at
penn state for for quite a while i
studied the behavioral
evolution ecology of social insects um i
had a lot of colleagues at the time and
a lot of friends who were also
both at my university and just sort of
in phd programs generally they started
saying a bunch of weird stuff about the
nature of biological sex you know things
like there's five sexes or sex is a
spectrum or male and female are just
social constructs they're not even real
we just you know sort of decide what we
call male and female but it's really
pretty arbitrary um
so i initially saw this as just uh you
know i had a history of sort of
debunking a lot of pseudoscience i used
to debunk things like creationism
intelligent design and so i just saw
this as another instance of like oh
these people are just wrong about really
obvious biology which is shocking
because a lot of them have phds in
biology but nevertheless i'm going to go
ahead and criticize these ideas the same
way i would have criticized anyone
making false claims about biology
well i thought i would be met with
you know scientific arguments and here's
some evidence of why why sex isn't real
this should be sort of a nobel prize
winning discovery of sex all of a sudden
male and female these aren't real
categories um that would have been
really shocking to me um but instead of
them coming at me with you know here's
the evidence here's why these are social
constructs it was
you're a bigot you're a transphobe etc
so i thought about not even
going that direction anymore and just
removing myself from the debate
completely because it was getting really
heated and i was on the market to you
know applying for professor jobs and
things like that at the time
but it really just sort of annoyed me
that
i had made it all this way into academia
i was about to start applying for jobs
as assistant professors you know these
are at major research universities and
i'm self-censoring on one of like the
most low-hanging fruit questions of
biology
are male and female real and so i sort
of asked myself what would christopher
hitchens do
and i just decided to write some more
articles on this
just debunking this hardcore
so that's what i did
there was a big swarm cancellation
attempt to to get me banned on twitter
to ruin my reputation so i can never get
hired i thought they were probably
successful in that so i ended up leaving
academia uh i worked for collette for a
while as their managing editor i since
left that i founded my own sub stack
called reality's last stand where i now
basically full time
go and debunk a lot of these arguments
of people denying
basic biology um and then i've expanded
a little bit to criticizing the sort of
gender ideology and queer theory that's
that's sort of producing all of this
insanity in the realm of of biological
sex and i also publish articles from
other people too so it's sort of like a
magazine sub stack of mostly my content
but anyone can publish there too um also
publishing a lot of case studies going
into these facebook groups with parents
which is this area where you know
parents still have a kid who's who comes
out as trans maybe they're four years
old maybe they're 12 years old uh and we
look at how these facebook groups are
really just sort of these
these gender ideology cults that
take a mom who's really nervous and
questioning what the hell is going on
with my son or daughter and these
facebook groups basically just
railroad these parents down the road to
transitioning their child um you know
getting double mastectomies having their
uh testicles removed everything so we're
exposing this type of stuff uh it's it's
pretty serious it's not for the faint of
heart and colin
when you were saying that you you
thought what would christopher hitchens
do number one i like the fact that
you've got a bottle of booze you would
do this yeah he would absolutely do this
but number two
didn't you worry that what you were
doing was committing professional
suicide
were you not concerned about that
well that was that was the reason that i
sort of withdrew for a while i had maybe
100 applications out actually turned my
my twitter i locked it down for
maybe six months while i was applying
for jobs um and when i was writing this
one essay the first one i wrote for
quillet called the new evolution deniers
one thing i did i sent it to my advisor
at the time some of my mentors
and they both came back and they said
this is a fantastic essay i agree with
everything it's completely right
but
you cannot publish this this will ruin
your career if you do publish it don't
put your name on it and
you know to me when the first thing they
said was though this is fantastic and
it's true
then to me everything after the but well
if i would have not went ahead and
published it that would have just been
you know every reason that i wanted to
get into science in the first place and
to be a scientist to pursue
truth to pursue what's real about
biology and the natural world
well all of a sudden it seemed like
academia really wasn't
what i wanted it to be like do i want to
work in an environment that is not going
to allow me to say completely
obviously true things is that male and
female exist so really um i know i no
longer even wanted to have that job
anymore given how much it's changed
since i had gone into it you know 12
years ago now at this point um so yeah
so i was actually okay with it
destroying my career um because i i
wanted to to be able to speak
the truth well colin one of the reasons
we wanted to speak with you again
obviously we had a great conversation
the first time uh and i feel like we
bang on about this trans issue so much
now i
almost don't want to talk about it quite
as much as we do but on the other hand
i think it's kind of like the coal face
of the whole battle with this
progressive mindset
and there are people like you who are
now increasingly paying a price as i
alluded to in the introduction and
you've just recently had a situation
where
not only have you been pushed out of
your career path you're not doing
science anymore you're doing something
else
but actually you are now being prevented
from being paid for the work that you do
by the payment systems that are supposed
to just be the lubricant of the market
tell us about that
yeah it's been it's been pretty nuts uh
so i left i was working at a
place called fair and i left
that job
because i wanted to go full time on my
sub stack to tackle the gender sex
denials and stuff because to me that's
just
it's like the eye of the storm it's the
the craziest stuff that's where i want
to focus all my attention um but then
that that's kind of a scary thing
because then i'm completely reliant on
payment processors i'm uh substack uses
stripe
they're pretty good um they've
kind of routinely come out pro free
speech and things like that but i was
also using
paypal to
solicit donations of people if they
didn't want to just subscribe to my sub
stack but they wanted to give me
donations directly monthly one-time
donations or whatever they could do so
through paypal
um so i had received an email from
paypal just out of the blue
just saying you can no longer use paypal
i think that was the
the subject line
and i thought this was had to be
completely oh that maybe
my credit card
is not working or i need to update
something uh and then going through you
know trying to to turn it back on well
there every everywhere i went led to
like a dead end so i called like the the
help desk just something is clearly
a miss here
and they said that you know they would
put me in touch with somebody who'd be
able to tell me what's going on expect
an email well i never got an email they
sent me a message through the paypal
system saying that if i want to find out
why my account was turned off that i
would need to submit have an attorney
submit a subpoena a legal subpoena to
find out
so
um yeah that's that's all i know they
didn't say any reason why my account was
shut down in the first place
uh
so if we can only imagine they've done
the same thing to ian miles chung uh
they recently also shut down mom's for
liberty account their paypal account so
this is sort of a pattern that they have
of people that they disagree with
politically on this um and it puts me in
a precarious position because i'm
completely reliant on these systems now
i don't work for a company i work for
myself and so i need to have a way where
people can pay me you know directly uh
or through through some sort of system
so it's really kind of a scary thing
we're just some some intern at paypal or
maybe it's at stripe now i hope i hope
they're as robust as i'm hoping they are
um but you know just a single click
and they can just turn off my entire
income and have you been able to appeal
or challenge in any way are you
considering following the legal route
i'm considering going and actually just
making them give me the reason so doing
the the subpoena route so that's sort of
in the works but um we're not quite
there yet uh and then also so it wasn't
just paypal but i also had an etsy store
you know it wasn't like a big part of my
income but every once in a while what is
it oh yeah
so etsy is like this online store that
people can set up their little shops it
was originally known for people selling
like homemade goods like they'd
knitting or something or they'd make
earrings with rocks or something like
that sounds like it should be yeah
exactly
and then it sort of expanded more and
now you can just host you can sell
anything you want to okay shirts mugs a
lot of people use it for that just
because it's got like low fees for
people who are hosting their stuff
um and then they sent me an email saying
that i could no longer use etsy and
permanently banned from etsy now they
did give me a reason they said that my
merchandise was i think the wording was
supporting and glorifying hatred against
protected groups
but if you actually saw the merchandise
that i had on there it was i literally
only sold three things i had so my my
sub stack is called reality's last stand
so i had some mugs that just had the
words realities last dan and they had a
male and a female symbol i had
another logo that said defender of
reality and it had male and female
symbol
i guess these are hate symbols now yeah
um and then i had my political cartoon
the poster i gave you of the one elon
musk tweeted out that just showed you
know how my perception sort of the left
had gone really left and the center had
moved past me now i'm perceived as being
on the right so that's there's nothing
hateful there
but apparently this was
was considered glorifying violence
against minorities i did try to appeal
and they said nope
we stand by our decision meanwhile they
do sell things that say like you know
kill turfs they have things that are
like turf stoppers and a turf is someone
who like criticizes gender ideology it
stands for trans-exclusionary radical
feminist and they have things that are
clearly glorifying violence against
those types of people um but i can't
sell just like a mug that has the name
of my
my sub stack on it apparently and colin
would you say to the argument that these
are private companies they can do
whatever they want if paypal doesn't
want to work with you why should paypal
be forced to same with etsy they have no
request no legal obligation to do so
what are you complaining about so i
there's there's actually like some
nuance to
my criticisms for both of them so
etsy you know it's annoying i have to
move my
my merchandise to some other place but i
can do it i'm setting up on a square
right now so um it's just an annoying
process i don't have
merchandise like in my closet or
anything like that it's sort of print on
demand so it's not like you know i have
to lug stuff to a new warehouse or
anything like that
but it is a little more sinister when
it's payment processors because they
portray themselves as these apolitical
things we're just you know letting
people
send money to you um
and so it's it's a little more intimate
than than just you know i gotta sell my
mug somewhere else uh so that is
i think
a conversation needs to be had about
that especially because
you know i'm fortunate i didn't have a
whole lot of people sending donations
through a place like paypal or through
paypal
but what they did you know it takes a
while you get people that will give you
recurring donations over time
and
if they cut that off
i can't just start charging those people
somewhere else they have to sign up
again somewhere else and fortunately it
was shut down early on when i didn't
have you know i wasn't relying on a lot
of this income from donations directly
but what if they shut it down
three years five years in the future
where it had grown and i'm relying on
that as a certain you know component of
my income for them to just be able to
cancel it completely
you know that's you know right now
they're allowed to do it as a private
company
but they do serve the role of sort of
like what a bank would normally be doing
and how you're getting payment so um i
do think they should be considered sort
of like a public service
um and the moment that politics gets
involved in payment processors that's
just it's going to turn the heat up of
the culture war to 11. i just it's
really really bad well this is why i
wanted to speak with you colin because
i'm i hope you're going to be okay i
think you will be yeah for the moment
but
the precedent that this set
is
it's actually very serious
because
i mean i i don't even know that if you
go to prison for a crime you you get
your bank account shut down yeah and
you've committed no crime and these
companies are unilaterally shutting down
your account in order to disincentivize
and discourage you from speaking about
something that you feel strongly about
and if we as you say go down that path
we're very quickly going to find that
people are having their electricity
switched off because they
they tweeted something that the
electricity company doesn't approve of
which is one of the reasons i was so
keen that we come out here and speak
with you to raise awareness of this
issue um
so
i suppose my i guess my question is how
do you see this continuing because
if we go down this route like i say
we're going to be you know shutting off
each other's electricity
before long yeah i mean i think we've
seen some of that
with the whole
things in canada with like the trucker
protest and you know they were shutting
down people's bank accounts for just
being at some of these trucker protests
so
um you know it's it's a really scary
time i don't i don't know where it's
gonna go but i think we need to do
everything we can to sort of lower the
temperature on this stuff
because i mean this is people's
livelihoods this is i mean a lot of
people are doing this now there's sort
of this new economy especially during
cove but everyone's switched to being
online we're relying more on things like
stripe and paypal and any other these
payment processors
we know that you know patreon they had a
big fiasco i think it was in 2018 where
they originally came out they even went
on dave rubin's show
the ceo did saying that you know
you're completely fine we're never going
to shut you down
our policy only happens to apply to
things that occur on patreon and then
you know was it a year later or
something he kicked off some people
because of stuff they did off patreon so
while i'm i feel relatively comfortable
with with stripe that's what powers
substack
who knows you know what if they get a
change of management what if all of a
sudden they decide that they want to
switch their policy up i mean these are
just personnel decisions at the end of
the day like who's there it matters the
composition of who's running these
companies and that can change really
dramatically so
um you know if we don't
really try to classify these things as
sort of just a general service provider
like a telephone company or something
um
yeah it's it's it's sort of a weird
i guess uh
i don't want to go and call it terrorism
but it is a way to to really just chill
speech on so many
uh so many levels because yeah it's and
designed to do so by the way exactly
it's designed to stop you from speaking
your mind with a click exactly um
well look i it's not for me to say
because i appreciate that it's not an
easy thing to do but i do hope that you
do pursue the legal subpoena route and
i'm sure people would be willing to help
if you were to go down that route
because as we will probably go on to
talk about what some of the things that
are happening in the uk now around the
trans issue we've seen that when legal
challenges are made to some of these
decisions they actually found unlawful
and and people
um
you know establish a precedent do you
have plans to do that uh in terms of the
subpoena and kind of going down right
yeah i'd like to pursue
that avenue i've been speaking to a few
lawyers about it but um we're sort of
just just talking at this point well i
hope you do yeah
hey francis do you want to protect your
privacy of course i do now that i'm an
international celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like the joe rogan
experience i have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the michael jackson of the internet
not the celebrity i would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
vpn i don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything frances remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a vpn
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch hd videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees
the great thing about expressvpn is that
you don't need any technical skills to
set up just like francis fire up the app
and it's one button to connect one tap
on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best vpn there is
business insider the verge and many
other tech journals raid expressvpn as
the number one vpn in the world go on
francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use our link expressvpn.com
trigger today and get an extra three
months free on a one-year package that's
expressvpn.com
trigger visit expressvpn.com trigger to
learn more she took everything
do you know what i find baffling about
this entire issue is number one we all
know what the truth is
number two trans women are women exactly
and trans men are with no men um
but why is it so toxic
yeah i mean i
it was me it was really shocking to me
because
i think as far as extremists on twitter
goes like i'm pretty low
on my extremism yeah
you're pretty chill yeah i'm much more
extreme than you i think yeah i mean i'm
not like a provocateur i'm not like
dunking on people i'm not telling people
they're groomers
like i think you should be allowed to
say that but you know i'm not there for
the clicks really i'm there to try to
just say like here's what biological sex
is here's why this argument's wrong i'm
pretty benign and so for that to happen
to me for them to like think that i'm
sort of beyond the pale to be treated on
par with like a domestic terrorist need
to shut down his
ways he can get income yeah it's it's
it's completely insane i don't know how
we got here why do you think they're
doing it to you
um you know i'd like to think it's just
because i'm really effective possibly
because i'm i'm kind of hard to
villainize in many ways
because i'm not the stereotypical like
right-wing pundit type person you know i
was kind of just happily in my in my lab
working with my spiders and wasps and
ants and i didn't want to have to like
sit up from my workbench
but i did and so uh and now i'm devoting
like all my time to this this one topic
and so i'm i'm really not the type of
person you'd expect
to be involved in these sort of culture
war issues if you can call that to me
it's not even i'm not even a culture
warrior i'm just someone talking about
biology and that's what i try to do so i
don't know maybe that's being really
effective maybe that's
that's the type of voice they want to
shut down because i'm sort of the
gateway to people who are pretty
reasonable on the left uh who wants
someone who's clearly not just you know
wearing a maga hat trying to tell them
you know what male and female are or
something so
and colin was there a specific moment
where you thought to yourself hang on
this is genuinely mental now
it was mental
from the beginning you know when people
were saying there's five sexes i mean
that's mental and when was this colin
this was i was probably seeing this
in like 2016 2016-17 wow and then it
wasn't in 2018 until i
actually wrote about it you know i just
wanted to stay under the radar because
every time i tried to touch it it just
it was an electric fence um
but really my my criticisms early on
about how just crazy these arguments
were was it was just a scientific
disagreement it was like these people
are just wrong about
what makes a male and a female
and then so my first articles really
show that they're just like here's what
a male is here's what a female is um
and it wasn't until later that i said
well let me look at where this is coming
from like so i looked at the queer
theory i looked at the gender ideology
that's producing this
and that's just when
it got really bonkers it's just like
this is just
completely detached from reality
and it's
you know when you're denying such a
fundamental aspect of what it means to
be
a homo sapiens a human being such as
there were
a species that has two sexes like every
other mammal um you know you can't just
get away with
with denying that and have not have
insane things crop up like this matters
for you know males now competing in
female sports males being transferred to
women's prisons because they just
identify as a woman and then raping
women who are in those prisons are
impregnating them and oh now we've got
to move them out and shuffle them around
it's like these are the kinds of things
that happen
when you're denying just these
fundamental aspects of human biology and
then as i mentioned i think before the
show i've been talking about going on
these
um these facebook groups with these
these parents who are having their kids
go through gender medicine you know kids
sometimes we had a mom talk about her
her four-month-old being trans because
when she says the word boy to her
daughter a boy kind of makes the or the
daughter sort of makes a weird frowny
face and so now they're talking about
you know transitioning this kid
parents talking about getting their
11 year olds on puberty blockers trying
to rush them to get double mastectomies
or to have their testicles removed
it's com i mean it's
it's been it was insane to begin with
and at every step along the line it's
just gotten more insane
so
yeah it's so crazy it's it's all crazy
so you use these these terms like queer
theory gender theory and all of this
can you explain what queer theory is
because i don't have the first idea i've
heard of it
it doesn't seem to me like any type of
i don't know serious investigative
subject i don't know if those are the
right words to use so explain to us what
this actually means yeah so someone like
james lindsay or helen plecos they could
give you the full
like underneath where everything in the
the intellectual history of this all to
sort of
boil it down i guess to what how this
how it manifests in the real world here
um
it's basically just this idea that
people are creating binaries in the
universe male or female
gay or straight things like this
and that these actually aren't realities
that
people reify these realities through
language
um in order to maintain and preserve
their own power in a certain situation
so they'll say something like
you know white colonialists uh invented
the idea of biological sex because they
wanted to oppress women um and this was
a and they'll even include racism in
this thing too and um uh of how you know
they've masculinized black women or
things like that so it's it's completely
insane it's just it's all using sort of
this
foucault um who's you know for
post-modern philosopher who thinks that
power dynamics are fueling basically
everything we know about reality in our
the way we use language structures
reality so they'll take something like
biological sex that we know i was
defined by like your reproductive
anatomy
and they'll say well here's an example
of a person who's got some sort of
ambiguous sexual anatomy well this calls
into question the entire
premise that there's only two sexes
um they basically just try to like blur
every single line that they can possibly
find in order to you know and if they
can find one way to blur something a
little bit
they'll just extend that blur to the
entire picture and say we have no idea
what we're talking about we're just
drawing these lines arbitrarily
everywhere but the fact that they even
know to think to to go to the intersex
people to to use them as an example
shows that well they actually know where
that line is because otherwise they
wouldn't know to go to that line um so
the fact that they know where to go to
try to like blow up these categories
shows that the categories themselves are
pretty robust because
they know exactly where the line is and
that's where they where they try to
drill in their ideology to
and uh we were speaking to a supporter
of ours earlier in this trip
about and he actually said that this
post-modernist stuff came to the hard
sciences first
um i don't know whether that's accurate
you're nodding is that is that accurate
so
yes so there was like the
um alan sokol
he was i think a physicist
and there were a lot of these like
post-modern journals that would you know
just using this new age jargon
post-modern type uh you know they were
completely nonsensical i can't even like
come up with them there's there's online
generators where you can just like
generate
titles for post-modern papers like this
um and you can't tell the difference
it's like here's a real one here's a
generated one you can't tell um and so
he ended up submitting a paper
that was completely made up just a bunch
of jargon words and he was able to get
it published and i think a pretty
substantial well post-modern journal at
the time and so that was the first like
so-called hoax of he punked these
post-modern journals and showed that
they're actually
completely devoid of all intellectual
rigor whatsoever
um so that was a big blow up and he's
kind of the kind of the postmodernism
went away um it was laughed out of the
room basically and then it kind of came
back in recently
well it's been in the universities but
it's been in like these humanities
departments but it's crept its way into
biology and a lot of other places um by
sort of cloaking themselves in rainbow
flags uh where before it was just sort
of like this crazy ideology you could
criticize it there was no social
repercussions for criticizing it it's
just this is crazy jargon haha um but
now it's like
when you criticize the jargon the senses
are like wreathed in a rainbow flag and
it's being used as sort of this lgbt you
know infused in all of their new
ideologies is that how it happens colin
because look i imagine most biologists
didn't go into biology
to pretend that there is a million
genders i mean they would have all been
taught i imagine at school as we were
about the basic biological nature of
humans and other mammals as you say so
how have we got to a point where someone
like you who continues to believe that
and advocate for that view is pushed out
is it cowardice do some of these people
are the actual converts in in your in
these departments and universities
why have we got an ideology that doesn't
make much sense in terms of the science
taking over
the hard sciences that we've all been
learning for
hundreds of years
i think a lot of people don't believe it
i mean i'm thinking
specifically i had some colleagues who i
was very close with who i know
don't believe any of this stuff at least
they didn't before beforehand i have you
know they've in just our private
communications we used to make fun of
the same type of stuff
some of them got jobs at universities
and two weeks later pronouns showed up
on their bios
and then i had even some of them one in
particular i'm thinking of send me a
text one day knowing that because i was
sort of getting more popular on twitter
talking about you know the sex and
debunking the sex spectrum things like
that and he just told me that i have a
lot of colleagues that are reaching out
to me saying that we had co-authored
papers together on spiders and wasps and
ants and things like that and they're
questioning me about you know our
relationship and i was like oh well i
mean you can just tell them
i don't agree with colin on these things
but we did good work on anson wasp and
that seems like it should be a pretty
easy conversation to have but no he's
like no i need to denounce you on on
twitter and social media
it's like okay i mean i'm fine people
criticizing my ideas but um you know
this this public denunciation process
really shows the mutual policing that's
going on so hold on i i we we're talking
about all this stuff like it's like
normal
what you're telling me yeah
hold on what you're telling me is that
there are biologists
at prominent institutions in the center
of learning of the western world the
united states
who don't believe that there is more
than two sexes but they will denounce
someone like you who says it
because they're terrified of the
repercussions for their career is that
what you're telling me 100 yeah i know
a lot of people reach out and you should
see my dms
there's so many biologists who reach out
saying that they won't even they don't
even want to like a tweet they'll send
me a dm saying i liked your tweet but i
couldn't like your tweet
[Music]
because i mean the social the mutual you
know social policing that's going on
they can't say these things so i i mean
isn't biology quite important like i'm
not just talking about the trans issue i
mean biology seems to me like quite an
important discipline for understanding
medicine and you know helping us move
forward in all sorts of ways so if we've
got people who are pretending
there's more than two sexes
and denouncing other colleagues in
public how
what impact is this going to have on
human progress well the impacts are
massive as i said this is a fundamental
aspect of our biology we've seen
places like the new england journal of
medicine probably the most prestigious
medical journal in the world published
papers about how we shouldn't even put
sex on birth certificates anymore
because this is irrelevant information
despite the fact that there's just these
reviews that are only from a couple
years ago
and and in the past talking about all
the sex differences and how heart
attacks and how cancer and you know the
list goes on and they conclude
how sex needs to be one of the first
variables that you that you know about
somebody when you want to talk about how
to give them proper medical care this is
all being erased now in certain areas
mostly canada but u.s big time as well
replacing biological sex with your
self-proclaimed gender identity but
see this is the thing
all right man
easy
easy breathe we've been on the right for
dinner yeah we've been on the road a
long time look
but this is science colin
this your scientists
that's why i'm no longer there yeah but
but you can't say there's five genders
if it's not true it's like saying a man
can turn into a fish if he just
identifies as a fish
i i completely agree yeah it's it's
it's so bonker i mean i i talk about it
really casually just because it's
what i do now but i'm fully aware that
it is just completely like weapons great
insanity it's it's it's completely
bonkers and and what does that mean for
science as a whole
and for society and for society i mean
one of the thing that pissed me off most
was
you know i
not only wanted to do research at like
the frontier of knowledge and push you
know push knowledge outward um but i
wanted i was inspired to be a scientist
by
really great science communicators like
richard dawkins and carl sagan people
like these who are just amazing science
communicators um so i wanted that i
wanted to be that person i wanted you
know in public trust and science you
need to have these really great
educators to do this
but then we have the same people who are
saying that
you know
sex is a social construct something that
children know is is a false statement
they know what males and females are um
the same people who are saying that you
know who are missing
whiffing the bat on the balls right
there on the t uh they're just whiffing
on that and then these are the same
people who are saying you know who are
doing something like
you know
disease epidemiology or they're doing
climate models that are just
orders of magnitude more complex than
males and females are real uh and we
expect to to believe these people what
they say about this now i'm not gonna i
don't want to say like we shouldn't
believe anyone i'm just saying that
if the public can see that they're
getting this question wrong what is the
male what is a female
they're just being lied to in their face
how can you expect them to
look into their same these same people's
faces when they tell you anything about
vaccines or anything about a
a
virus that is spreading across society
what policies are the best thing
anything about climate change you can't
you can't trust anybody
and i think just what the biological sex
debate is doing is it's
it is making people just throw up their
hands and say we can't trust any of
these people and i don't blame them and
that's why i just i'm trying to get
people back to the basics on what
science is you know i i didn't want to
be in the sciences anymore talking about
things on the frontier of you know
social insect behavior knowing that
half of my classes maybe thinks that
there's five sexes
and colin uh i know this is not strictly
speaking your discipline so if if you
don't want to answer don't but what is
your view of the idea of the existence
of gender identity do you believe there
is such a thing
no not in the way that it's usually
defined by like a lot of the gender okay
well let's break it down right so the
idea of gender identity is basically the
sex your body is male and my body is
male and your girlfriend's body's female
but
she can feel like a man yeah and i can
feel like a woman and then that's what
makes her a man and that's what makes me
a woman if that's what i feel yeah that
that's how i would describe it yeah is
that simple is that is that accurate so
i've heard people tell me that they
definitely have this feeling that
that they would call a gender identity i
don't know if they're just like
identifying with their femininity or
masculinity
i don't know what that means like
to me like i don't identify
as a man i guess that makes me
non-binary by that definition like i'm
just i'm a biological male and i define
a man as an adult human male right so
that then that label applies to me i
don't know what it means to identify as
it um just like i don't identify as
straight even though like the label
applies because i'm not attracted to men
i'm attracted to women it's not an
identity it's just a descriptor of
my my preferences you know uh i'm a man
it's a descriptor of the fact that i'm
an adult human male 1 so based on that
there is no such thing as gender
identity yeah well there's some trans
people
that they have gender dysphoria yes
that's what i was gonna say but that's
just like a that's that's separate
though that's a whole that's
they have a condition
where they feel that there is this
incongruity yes it doesn't mean that
you and me who don't feel it incongruity
have a gender identity the only reason
that we don't call ourselves trans is
because or we don't feel dysphoria is
because our identity and our bodies
matches like they have an actual
psychological condition that's that's
making them feel like when they look in
the mirror there's this sort of
disconnect there and this is the same
regions in the brain that that light up
when people are like anorexic for
instance and they look in the mirror and
they're rail thin but they think they're
fat you know the same regions in the
brain
light up for those people as for people
who you know identify as training so
it's a condition in the same way let if
we said you know there are people who
believe that they have an arm that they
don't need for example yeah that does
not mean that we have like a body
integrity identity it just means this
person has a particular condition that
makes you exactly feel this way yeah
okay so some people might have what they
consider to be a gender identity but i
think most people probably don't they
just
they're a male they're they're a man
because they're adult human male and
they recognize that fact you know the
thing that worries me as well colin is
just
how powerful this ideology is and it
just seems that all these corporations
they use it you know in academic
institutions it seems now everybody has
got pronouns in their bio even if
they're you know a retired mma fighter
with a beard they've got pronouns he him
what why is it so powerful this ideology
i think a lot of it is sort of what i
mentioned earlier how it's it's cloaked
itself in the rainbow flag um
it
it's it's a lot of just like this social
mutual policing as well that's going on
um you know the pronouns
i wrote a piece about this for the wall
street journal about you should why you
shouldn't
participate in these pronoun rituals
that i call them
um because it really is sort of like a
wedge for gender ideology to get in
there because
what it tells you what people are saying
when they want to ask your pronouns is
they're saying that
there's something different there's a
gender identity and then there's your
sex so when you ask somebody you know
what are your pronouns i can clearly
identify that you're males so if i'm
asking you what are your pronouns that's
saying that there's there could be some
other your brain might be different in
some way you might identify
as a woman or something um
and so what that does is it sort of
greases the wheels for gender ideology
so if you were to say that you know if i
might respond that well my my pronouns
are he him i'm just saying that because
i'm an adult human male that's what i
think that's i'm using sex-based
pronouns but since the gender ideologues
the way they define males and females is
according to like these social roles and
expectations based on your sex so you
know i'm responding based on what my sex
is what they hear is that i identify
with these stereotypes of masculinity
etc and so
that's not what i'm saying um and
that ideology actually reifies these
sexist notions that
you can't be
a man unless you're masculine and you
can't be a female or woman unless you're
feminine um this is something that you
know i think a lot of the feminist
movement
had worked tirelessly to dissociate
these notions of womanhood and manhood
from these stereotypes of masculinity
and femininity and the gender ideology
comes in and just
fuses them back together again and
pronouns is one way that they're doing
that that's
uh one way that they get their foot in
the door to sort of normalize this
disconnect between your sex and your
gender identity across society most
people are even asking you what your
pronouns are at like a
at a university or at a corporation they
probably don't even know what they're
doing they're just told this is an
inclusive language to use uh but it's it
should be resisted because that is
normalizing this gender ideology and
that sex and gender are these
wildly different things and
that you know you can be a male but you
can really be a woman
hey francis do you believe in diversity
and inclusion of course i do my dating
history is filled with diversity and
inclusion i am nothing if not an equal
opportunities employer all your previous
partners do seem to be of the same sex
i'm not that inclusive but if you are
worried about the polarizing effect of
diversity and inclusion in workplaces
then you have to attend the
counterweight conference on liberal
approaches to diversity and inclusion
we've had people from counterweight on
this very show to talk about how this
can be achieved they're great people who
want to improve society counterweight
believe that there is a need for
diversity and inclusion that aims to
eliminate workplace racism and
discrimination through a liberal and
unifying lens the current way isn't
working and we need a less divisive
approach the speakers are also former
guests of ours including eric kaufman
they're also giving free access for a
very limited time to a huge variety of
resources showing how diversity and
inclusion can be done properly without
all the reactionary nonsense peddled by
those who shall not be named so if
you're interested in making your
workplace better for everyone then you
have to check out the counterweight
conference on liberal approaches to
diversity and inclusion we promise there
won't be any lectures with titles like
why painting your bathroom why is a
microaggression it's an online
conference on the 22nd to the 25th of
september go to cw dot h e y s u m m i t
dot com and use our code trigger pod 20
at checkout for twenty percent off an
all access pass go to
dot cw.heysummit.com and use our code
trigger pod 20 at checkout for 20 off
and all access pass
where are we uh in the attempt to
challenge some of this
in the time that francis and i've been
traveling around the u.s the last couple
of weeks we've seen in the uk quite a
bit of progress being made we've seen
the shutting down of the tavistock
clinic we had marcus evans a
whistleblower from that clinic on the
show
and that was shut down because there
were concerns that children were being
railroaded down the path to transition
when it wasn't the right answer for
their particular problems we've seen the
maya four starter case recently in the
uk the allison bailey case uh and on and
on and on we go
it seems to me that we are making some
progress in the uk thank god
where are you in the us
nowhere near where the uk is you know
the uk is really inspirational and we're
hoping that we can point to
the uk and a lot of other
uh european countries because a lot of
you know finland and sweden they've
changed some of their gender policies
backed away from this affirm only
approach and you know therapy first and
that type of thing
um because a lot of people on the left
in the u.s like to point to european
countries to be like oh how progressive
they are and so if they're changing
their policies and maybe that'll make
them think like maybe we should put them
on the brakes a little bit well we are
progressive
by comparison to the yes we're is not
insane yeah exactly um the us we're
making some progress on the sports front
like there's been some organizations
that have come out and changed updated
their policies on um you know how
males can compete in female sports um
but really past that
not much uh
yeah i can't there's there's some
lawsuits that are being done right now
in california about um
males being transferred to female
prisons
but everything is still very much moving
towards the firm only you know we have
biden administration by income out there
the best thing you can do is affirm your
transgender child rachel levine
the transgender admiral health person
saying the same thing you know these
this is just wildly incongruent with
some of the the review studies that have
been taking place in
in the uk and finland and sweden um and
the only place in the us that has done a
similar like
uh non-partisan review had been florida
and then they've all they've also
concluded that you know this affirm only
approach needs to be backed away from
and um they need to sort of do more
explorative therapy before
we put kids down this pathway to you
know to irreversible surgeries in you
know in the uk we've got you know heroes
like kiera bell who i'm sure you know of
who
went
quite a lot of the way
through her transition
before realizing that it was desperately
wrong and being left
unfortunately really severely harmed by
these drugs do you think that the real
pushback will happen when we get a wave
of d transitioners in the us
suing these clinics
suing these these surgeons etc that's
the moment when people are going to wake
up when it's actually going to hit them
in their pocket yeah as soon as the
lawyer starts swarming there needs to be
sort of a precedent-setting lawsuit i
think that goes through the uk has that
with cura bell we don't have anything
like that in the u.s at the moment um i
don't know if you've been driving you've
been driving a lot in the u.s you
probably see a lot of these signs
you know have you been injured at work
call call me i'll get you your money you
know there's all these you know we're a
really litigious society in the us
and you know i've been talking to some
lawyers who are really kind of pivoting
because they think this is going to be a
big area sort of the gender medicine
people being damaged in the next couple
years and coming out and saying that you
know why was i allowed to chop my
breasts off at 13.
and so
i can imagine
billboards that are going to be you know
were you transitioned at you know a
young age where you put on blockers were
you given a mastectomy when you were a
child um once that happens once the
lawyer starts swarming
i think it's going to be game over for
that i mean that's
yeah
colin
i i don't know about you i sometimes you
know what really worries me about this
and obviously
it's the children it's the women who are
being raped in prison it's all of that
and that's terrible it's awful really is
and also on top of that i just wan
it's kind of i'll be honest with you i'm
just being very honest with you it it
kind of
undermines my faith in humanity quite a
bit because i go well if if a
significant number of people are
prepared to go along with this
like
what else can we be persuaded to go
along with in the name of ideology or
just to avoid being fired from our
universities or whatever like
does do you sometimes feel like this is
kind of a sign of just like a society
that's gone a bit mad
yeah i mean i've been really
i guess
saddened i guess by the fact that so
many people
can listen to these
obvious falsehoods about biological sex
things like that
and just
just take it and just swallow it and
parrot it without even thinking like
it's
it's one of the most insane things i can
imagine someone actually believing and
then
throwing back out there and then also
not even just to be you know be one
thing if it was just people online
saying this stuff but to have
institution after institution being
completely captured by this
um i mean i have an article i'm working
on
that
looks at sort of the the main scientific
institutions that we have and also the
human rights institutions and how
they're defining what it means to be
transgender now and how
in the literal definitions of the
planned parenthood human rights campaign
they talk about how you're transgender
if your gender identity
doesn't conform with your sex assigned
at birth but then they also say or your
gender expression
uh so gender non-conformity basically is
how they're defining being trans now and
then you go to the places like the cdc
center for disease control the us
uh to the endocrine society to the
american psychiatric society they are
all defining transgenderism according to
gender non-conformity now if you just
don't a fine with the
roles and expectations that society
assigns you based on your your sex this
is how they're defining it in all these
institutions right now so they've been
captured
and it makes people like me sound like
this alex jones tin hat
because parents say what do i do and i
can't say
talk to your doctor
look at the go to the cdc website go to
the
american
psychiatric website because they've all
been captured and i sound like you know
i got this twirler on my head
but you can't because they have been
captured by this ideology
um and so i don't know i mean people
just have to think for themselves now
and that's kind of frightening to be
completely abandoned by all the
institutions that we're supposed to to
trust
and
that
means it's a society is in a very
dangerous place
i mean this is like
collapse level i mean i don't see how it
can be
can be stopped
really
because they're they're captured you
can't even get a foot in the door
because you just get
you get kicked out well the uk hopefully
setting setting some examples that can
be used that can give cover perhaps you
know that can encourage certain states
at least to start to look at some of
these studies uh you're not you're not
persuaded that's going to happen
i don't know i mean i've heard people
say that the u.s is particularly crazy
because they have sort of this
financial incentives like the healthcare
sort of a free-for-all yeah um you know
that makes sense of you know if you have
a centralized health agency like the in
the uk
um they can
be more equipped to sort of
push back against these things because
they don't have like just these
independent companies that are competing
for this stuff but then you look over at
canada and they have public health too
but
they're all completely captured because
you know their their far right is still
like
to the left in the u.s
so it can go either way you know if
you're if your society is like super far
left on everything and you have a
nationalized health care then
you're in bad luck
if you have a system like in the uk
where it's nationalized but they're just
a little more i guess reasonable on
certain things or there's a little more
bipartisan going in there um that can
work out well in the u.s it could go
either way depending on where the money
is so
um
yeah it could also be a colin like in
the us you just need some angry lesbians
on it yeah i mean those
they've been doing all that a lot of
stuff in the uk yeah they're incredibly
organized in turf islands sorry that was
a cheap that was a cheap joke but
but but we're being flippant but it's
true
a lot of lesbians have been at the
forefront of this pushing back because
they know that they would have been that
kid who was probably very tomboyish as a
as a girl
they would have been targeted by gender
ideology
from a very young age and told that they
were probably a boy because of their
more masculine
uh preferences and behaviors and colin
how much of this do you think is about
technology you know we were just on joe
rogan's show and this is one of the
things we were discussing because i i
have a feeling that of course ideology
is important and a very powerful tool
but
how much of this is to do with the fact
that we are now approaching
the stage where we have drugs that sort
of can sort of block puberty and we have
surgeries that we can now do that can
sort of imitate the genitals of the
opposite sex how much do you think this
has been enabled by the creation of new
technology
yeah i mean those are those are things
that
i mean they're big
innovations i suppose if you want to
call them that
um
i think
you know i i'm all for people to choose
whatever pathway if you want to have
a vaginoplasty and have it make look or
i guess they would call that a
phalloplasty and have it make it look
like a penis
you know if if you're over 18 and this
is something you want to do i mean maybe
even not then because you you know you
still should have doctors that are not
just saying like whatever you want to do
but if we want to treat it the same way
we treat like a breast implants or
something where you know you can do
these elective surgeries i think maybe
some people should be allowed to do that
um
really it comes down to
whether children can consent to those
yes
and you know they'll say something like
you know well some kids would benefit
from having their puberty blocked
because you know people like
you know there's a lot of trans women
who've went through male puberty and i'm
sure that they would have appreciated
not having these secondary sexual
characteristics that are hard to reverse
so they don't so that they would pass
better like yeah they would probably be
happier but the thing is
how can you tell exactly which kid is
gonna grow up and
be grow up to still be trans and how
many kids are we willing to incorrectly
put on puberty blockers and transition
um you know what's the sort of the type
one error the false
false positive rate that we're willing
to deal with i think just because some
kids might theoretically
be happier when they grow up
i mean some kids who have body
dysmorphia might be happier if you
chopped a leg off you know
maybe there's a kid out there who would
think that do i think that means we need
to like find that kid who would be
really happy with their legs chopped off
and then how many kids are we gonna be
happy with you know chopping their legs
off to save that those kids who would
have been happy as adults being legless
you know i think we can step back and
say
you know some kids are gonna probably
just have to be unhappy
as adults and wish that they had gone
these things i don't think that is
necessarily means we need to do
everything we can to find those people
if it means that there's gonna be some
bycatch where other kids are going to be
incorrectly transitioned um and it's
such a good point colin because it just
seems that more and more young girls are
identifying
with this particular ideology whereas
when i was a teacher 10
when i was teaching secondary school 10
years ago
unfortunately the mental illness for
girls at that time
teenage girls and was anorexia bulimia
but now it seems to have gone to they
they identify as trans yeah that's i
mean largely i think that's because
well we've changed the definition of
what it means to be trans to encompass
just common gender non-conformity
when you look at the rates of gender
nonconformity in males versus females
females
are more gender non-conforming on
average than males are so we talk about
this you know this dramatic rise in the
number of kids who are identifying as
trans and then we also talk about oh the
sex ratio has also flipped it used to be
more boys now it's more females and
people who think this is a big mystery
well why is it well if you change the
definition to gender non-conformity
right you have more females who are more
likely to be gendered on conforming well
that explains the dramatic rise and the
sex ratio flip
right there and there we are
colin
i'm gonna be honest with you man like we
have talked this issue to death we
really really have but i think the point
that we were
kind of exploring with you about what
this means for science is actually the
one
you know the kids and the people who are
going to be affected by this that's
tragic
but the consequence for for society more
broadly is is just terrifying to me so
um and of course then there's the
financial stuff that we talked about
earlier as well so first of all i hope
you continue to do the work that you're
doing and i
everybody should check out your sub
stack and support you if they can but i
also do hope you pursue the subpoena and
you get a legal situation there because
this is this is how it happened in the
uk and it's a lot to put on your
shoulders i'm not saying you have to be
the guy that does it but that's the way
we've seen it
happen in the in the uk so i hope there
are people who are watching this or
perhaps in your position as well who
either want to help you or want to to
pursue that because that is the way that
i think this is likely to end
anyway thank you for giving us your time
uh thanks for coming on the show uh as
always what is the one thing that we're
not talking about because we are talking
about this now let's be honest the trans
issue we are talking about everybody's
talking about it everybody's talking
about it what is the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that you
think we really should be
so this is something that some people
are talking about
but
i think it's a really important thing
about
how we kind of are able to be in the
moment we're in right now with regarding
trans issues like how did
this just blow up where trans issues
were nothing
now all of a sudden it's this
multi-billion dollar industry how does
this occur
i think it needs
we need to sort of step back and take a
look at how how nonprofits are
structured i mean you look at these
places like the human rights campaign
like the aclu
you can see their messaging when they're
when they were trying to fight back
against
largely conservatives who were against
gay marriage gay marriage was an
extremely popular uh thing i'm very
pro-gay marriage um and so they got tons
of funding billions of dollars in these
organizations to combat gay marriage
and then what happened
2015 i think what it was it became law
of the land they won
well what do you do you know most of
their money was in these issues and you
can look at like just the next year of
these organizations
of you know how much they were paying
for gay rights stuff or how much did
they use the word gay in their messaging
and we can see just overnight it flipped
where all these billions of dollars
because you know they're not just going
to shutter their doors
you know we we won okay
you know they have payrolls they have
people are making a lot of money off
this it's a non-profit maybe at the
the level of the organization or
whatever but people are still making
money doing this stuff and so they just
shunt all their money into the next
issue they have to find
they have to create a big issue
even if there's none that exist at the
time and the issue they have to make
they have to justify
it being worth all the billions of
dollars that they got for gay marriage
so it needs to be just as important as
that
so that has all been shifted to the
whole trans issue which is why we have
this enormous
apparatus this organized system uh that
everyone is just scrambling now to to
recover from
um i think this is just sort of a
natural pathway that a lot of these
non-profits take when
when society is actually improving
you know the big wins that you have
these cathartic releases that you have
are getting smaller and smaller because
you sort of asymptotically approach
an ideal
state
and so then it becomes enticing to do
like just the opposite well what's the
new best idea what's going to give you
that cathartic release well let's maybe
go back a few notches now and say that
you know just the opposite is true sex
is not real
these are social constructs actually
focusing more on race is better than
color blindness you know all of a sudden
just the opposite of progress becomes
enticing and is what these organizations
do because you know they need to find
something huge to push back on i don't
know how we solve it but it is seems
like the natural course that a lot of
these nonprofits take where they just
they have to survive somehow
they have to find a way to to justify
these billions of dollars that they're
getting and it really just wreaks havoc
on society when they when they have
nothing else to do so they need to make
make something up it's what they call
sin georgian retirement syndrome where
he goes around killing snakes instead of
having defeated the great dragon anyway
colin thank you so much for coming on i
remind everybody where they can follow
you and follow your work
so you can follow me on twitter at swipe
right that's swipe
w-r-i-g-h-t
uh my sub-stack is where i sort of
debunk a lot of the sex and gender
arguments it's realities last stand.com
um that's pretty much where you can find
me all right thanks for thanks for
hosting us and letting us use this space
to record this interview with you and
thank you guys for watching and
listening we'll see you very soon with
another interview like this one or raw
show all of them go out at 7 p.m uk time
and we have also got questions for our
locals so come and support us on locals
and you'll be able to ask questions to
all our fantastic guests and colin uh
on our locals and for those who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
[Music]
are other evolutionary biologists like
jerry coyne p z myers and richard
dawkins coming to your defense or
reaching out to you or are you on your
own when you're speaking out about this
issue
[Music]